großbritannien steuert auf den harten
drechsel zu das wissen sie
es bleibt leider kaum noch zeit für
verhandlungen und das befürchtete
szenario wird immer wahrscheinlicher
trotzdem ist premier ministerin may beim
parteitag ihrer konservativen tories
diese woche ja geradezu beschwingt zum
rednerpult getänzelt zu abbas dancing
queen
tja das war nicht schlecht vor nicht
oder es kann man kann man machen vor
allem war es natürlich eine
selbstironische anspielung weißraum
inzwischen einen ruf hat als legendär
schlechte tänzerin neulich beim afrika
besuch hat sie ja im prinzip so was wie
den tanz zum rexit aufgeführt
[Musik]
das duo chicago
schinkel
schön dass du
schluss damit
kurz danach hat es in afrika zwölf
wochen am stück geregnet
eigentlicher star des parteitags der
tories war aber natürlich ihr fein ihr
konkurrenten boris johnson
ex-außenminister und völlig
durchgeknallter braig sieht hardliner ja
meine der mann hat gar kein amt mehr
gilt aber als kommender herrscher der
insel
er findet frau mails pläne den checkers
plan ich zitiere geisteskrank was aus
seinem mund irgendwie lustig klingt aber
aus seinem mund klingt ja fast alles
lustig die eu erinnert mich ein wenig an
schlechten seite unterhosen angekommen
solche die an einigen stellen zu eng
sind in viel zu engen und an anderen
dann wiederum die geradezu gefährlicher
weise zu weit nicht drüber nachdenkt
vertrauen sie mir führt nirgendwo hin
er ist führt nirgendwo hin die brics it
befürworter haben null plan für den
ausstieg 0
sie sind mehrfach beim lügen erwischt
worden und lügen jetzt unsere dreister
weiter als außenminister hat die eu
gerade in dieser woche als gefängnis
bezeichnet und mit der sowjetunion
verglichen die eu nur weil sie nach
einem austritt nicht mehr den vollen
zugang zu unseren binnenmarkt hätten ihr
wolltet doch raus für diese vögel
braucht man inzwischen einen exorzisten
freunde ernsthaft ja ist ja nicht
übertrieben hier engländer die tante
angela erklärt euch das noch mal wie
sehr sehr doofen kindern
aber es gibt eben auch ein paar maßstäbe
und einer dieser maßstäbe ist dass man
nicht zum binnenmarkt gehören kann wenn
man nicht teil des binnenmarktes ist ja
genau engländer nur wenn man im
binnenmarkt ist ist man im binnenmarkt
kapiert gott komm ich mache noch
einfacher guck mal das hier ist meine
neue boris johnson sockenpuppen guck mal
und das hier ist die eu ja jetzt ist der
ball ist drin oder raus
drinnen draußen aber hier habe ich ja
kein markt mehr
aber du wolltest doch raus als die
freizeit sag mal
es hat ja keinen sinn
es bringt ja nichts die meisten von
denen sind argumenten gar nicht mehr
zugänglich es ist eine insel mit
begrenztem platz wenn man sie füllt ohne
kontrolle darüber
womit wird sie sinken sie wird
untergehen ja das ist fakt jede insel
hat ein bestimmtes fassungsvermögen ja
wenn du da nur einen dicken polnischen
klempner zu viel ein wandern lässt
dann kippt mich nur die stimmung dann
läuft der ganze laden ab das ist
schlecht
schwerkraft auf kritisch
dass das müssen wir natürlich ganz
realistisch sehen ratschläge aus
deutschland wollen die briten als
allerletztes aber einen mann hält das
nicht ab
gernot hassknecht jano task erklärt den
hang ländern was nach dem brett
passieren wird in 150 sekunden
sehr geehrte engländer die ihr brit
meine lieben sommersprossige freunde
die uhr tickt so clock is ticking am 29
märz 2009 10 um punkt elf uhr abends
seid ihr raus dass ihr geht aber ja es
steht mir bis hier los ist plus dieser
arroganz mit biene aber es wäre
womöglich ein wirtschaftliches desaster
und alles hängt das glaube ich noch ich
wüsste nicht warum wenn wir die besten
produkte in der welt produzieren
dann werden diese auch andere länder
weiterverkaufen das muss wohl der
berühmte britische humor sein
dieses widerliche mir dass man mit
messer und gabel trinken muss ein
händler
ihr habt eine acht um negative
handelsbilanz ihr seid import süchtig
allein könnt ihr euch nicht waren brot
schmieren das belegte pausenbrot das
sandwich ist in gefahr käse aus irland
dänischer schinken gurken aus holland
und tomaten aus spanien gibt euch doch
einfach ein bisschen von eurem berühmte
sich drauf
und schmeckt kein mit im letzten jahr
importierte großbritannien 3000 sperma
spenden von der größten europäischen
samenbank in dänemark unfassbar tv zum
selber wechseln
damit ist bald feierabend nie schneiden
euch von der stromversorgung ab mit
wikinger gene dann müsst ihr euch wieder
aus eurem eigenen bienen lang britischen
notenbank chefs kosten der brad pitt den
durchschnittshaushalt jetzt schon 900
pfund pro jahr und für alle denen das zu
kompliziert ist stelle ich den weiteren
verlauf des exit hier mal symbolisch da
mit einem doppeldeckerbus
[Musik]
in diesem sinne gute fahrt oder auf
englisch
[Applaus]
bernhard gruber